these proposals mr speaker will make it
easier for clinicians for carers and
public health experts to achieve
what they already work hard to do to
operate
seamlessly across health and care
without being split into artificial
silos that keep them apart
the new approach is based on the concept
of population health
a statutory integrated care system will
be responsible in each part of england
for the funding
to support the health of their area they
will provide
not just for the treatments that are
needed but support people to stay
healthy
in the first place in some parts of the
country
ics's are already showing the way and
they will be accountable for
outcomes of the health of the population
and be held to account
by the care quality commission our goal
is to integrate decision making at a
local level between the nhs and local
authorities as
much as is practically possible and
ensure decisions about local health can
be taken as locally as possible
next mr speaker will use legislation to
remove bureaucracy that makes sensible
decision-making
harder so freeing up the system to
innovate
and to embrace technology as a better
platform
to support staff and patient care our
proposals preserve the
division between funding decisions and
provision of care
which has been the cornerstone of
efforts to ensure the best value for
taxpayers for over
30 years but we're setting out a more
joined up approach
built on collaborative relationships so
that more strategic decisions could be
taken
to shape shape health and care for
decades to come
at its heart it's about population
health
using the collective resources of the
local system
the nhs local authorities the voluntary
sector and others
to improve the health of the area
finally mr speaker the white paper will
ensure a system
that is accountable ministers have
rightly
always been accountable to this house
for the performance of the nhs
and always will clinical decisions
should always be independent but when
the nhs
is the public's top domestic priority
with over 140 billion pounds of
taxpayers money spent each year
and when the quality of our healthcare
matters to every
single citizen and every single one of
our constituents mr speaker
of course the nhs must be accountable to
ministers
ministers accountable to parliament and
parliament accountable to the people we
all serve medical matters are
matters for ministers the white paper
provides a statutory basis for unified
national leadership of the nhs
merging three bodies that legally
oversee the nhs into one
as nhs england nhs england will have
clinical and day-to-day operational
independence
but the secretary of state will be
empowered to set direction for the nhs
and intervene where necessary we are not
surprised he has ended up
here we warned ministers not to go ahead
with the cameron lansley changes
10 years ago a reorganization so big you
could see it from space it cost millions
it demoralized
staff it ushered in a decade of wasted
opportunity and of course he voted for
them
he defended them in this chamber so i
hope when he stands up
he will tell us he was wrong to support
them then
now we have long argued for more
integrated care but how will these new
structures be governed
how will they be accountable to local
people how will financial
priorities be set because when something
goes wrong
as tragically sometimes it does go wrong
in delivery of care
or when there are financial problems
like we've seen at leicester's
trust where does the book stop
when he voted for the cameron
reorganization 10 years ago
it was because he wanted i presume in
the words of the white paper at the time
to liberate the nhs but now he's
proposing
a power grab that was never consulted on
by the nhs
it seems he wants every dropped bed plan
to reverberate around whitehall
again and he's announcing this just at
the nation
in striking contrast to delivery of test
and trace to ppe early on
where he was responsible so again we
will look carefully at the legislation
but why is he so keen for these new
powers why is he
is he refusing why is he um repealing
his responsibility to set an annual
mandate and bring it
to parliament he wants to intervene now
in hospital reconfiguration plans
but why is he stripping local
authorities of their power to refer
controversial plans
to him and with his new powers will he
reverse outsourcing
will he end the transfer of staff to
subcose will he bring contracts back
in-house and block more outsourcing in
the future he is ditching the
competition framework
for the tendering of local services
while while potentially replacing it
with institutionalized cronyism at the
top instead
and fundamentally how will this
reorganization and power grab
improve patient care he didn't mention
waiting times in his statement
it's mentioned once in the leaked white
paper so how will he bring waiting lists
down
how will he improve cancer survival
rates and widen access
to mental health care and by when how
will this reorganization
narrow widening health inequalities and
by when and given the prime minister
insist lessons can't be learned from
this pandemic until the crisis
is over why does he disagree with that
and consider this reorganization
so urgent now